hi everyone i'm dave rowe i'm a phd
candidate in rae kong's group at the
university of minnesota
and i study bioinformatics and in this
talk i'm going to be talking about
a dna interpretation of the cure region
and especially a project that we have to
efficiently
capture uh sequence assemble
and annotate cure habla types cure
stands for
killer cell immunoglobulin-like
receptors these are
receptors on natural killer cells and
they
recognize hla antigens and they
are part of the response that the nk
cell has
to different conditions including a
viral responses
this is a slide or a picture
from the amino polymorphism database
the vertical bar on the left depicts
chromosome 19
and on the long arm on the bottom a good
chunk of that is
expanded on the right vertical bar which
is the leukocyte receptor complex and
part of that
lrc is the cure region
there's one structure shown here but
actually there are many different care
structures
as far as what's been reported as
references in the human genome project
we have haplotypes ranging in size from
four genes
to 18 genes
this shows the most frequent haplotype
structure it's called the a haplotype
it's 135 000 base pairs long it contains
nine genes that are that range between
ten and sixteen thousand base pairs
it contains seven protein coding genes
and two pseudo genes
it also contains a particularly strong
recombination
hot spot right in the middle
this is a comparison of that a half a
type at the top with another haplotype
called the b haplotype on the bottom
and you can see that every cure every
gene on the a haplotype has at least one
equivalent on the
b habit type and one gene has more than
one equivalent
and the b habit type has at least three
genes here i guess that
are not present in the a haplotype
there are 14 reference structures in the
human genome reference for
here here's some six of them the tallest
one is shown at the top
it has 18 genes and the smallest one
which actually isn't depicted here has
four genes like i mentioned
um before most of
all of the reference habla types or most
of them anyway in the human
genome reference were um submitted um in
sequence by
dan garrity's lab at the university of
washington and cisco genomics
and what he does is he uses phosmine
library preparation to separate
the maternal and paternal chromosomes
and then sequence them
pac bio and because they use library
preparation they can get read links of
tens of thousands of base pairs
and that's how they were able to
contribute these to the human genome
reference
and this this is what we use as the
ground truth for our project
but our goal was to use high throughput
next generation
sequencing methods to develop a full
haplotype
system a system that labs can use
that don't even have to know anything
about cure in order to efficiently
sequence and assemble
the primary barrier to doing this in the
past at the high throughput ngs
workflow is the homology and
this dot plot shows the alignment
between a haplotype on the y curve on
the y axis
and a b haplotype on the x axis
and every red dot is a match between the
two haplotypes
and you can see that not only are the
two hepatites in general
homologous but every gene is homologous
to every other gene
and this is what causes the most
problems for
interpretation for example if you try
and
align reads to a cure reference you're
going to get reads that multi-align
some reads will align to almost every
gene in the alignment
and as a bioinformatics person i
this is a problem and it's frustrating
but the key innovation that we have for
our new library preparation is we want
to take advantage of that homology
if we have to pay the price for it on
the bioinformatics interpretation
let's take advantage of it from the
capture and
capture use the homology to capture
multiple
regions with just one probe
and so that's how we went about
designing our probes we partnered with
idt
and they gave us a candidate senate we
gave them some cure sequences
they gave us a candidate set of probes
and then i used the domain knowledge
that
i that i have for here to optimize those
probe sets
this picture shows a hapless a b
haplotype that's almost 200 000 base
pairs long
the the vertical bars at the top are the
where the genes are annotated
and then in the middle it shows we zoom
into a
region that's approximately 50 000 base
pairs
and we show the alignment of the 120
base pair capture probes
against this haplotype
with our capture method the
fragment lengths are about 5 000 base
pairs
on average so we needed to have capture
probes um
less than that um every 4 4 500 is what
we
ended up with and
the yellow arrows show the order of the
probes each probe has a number
so from left to right the number starts
off 4 3 12
10 2 etc
and then below those probes um at the
very bottom
the blue horizontal bars are annotation
of the transposable and repetitive
elements
that are in the haplotype and also the
exons
it was important to have our probes miss
those regions because
some of the pure exons are very
polymorphic and that polymorphism might
cause the probes not to be able to hit
them and
the repetitive elements it's important
to avoid those so we don't
get off cure reads fragments
and the thing i'd like to point out next
is
the order of the probes repeats so it
starts off 4
3 12 10 but then about 10
000 base pairs later it also repeats 4
3 12 no 10 this time and then
10 000 base pairs later approximately
repeats again
4 3 12 10 and this shows that
since these probes are hitting in
multiple spots along the chromosome
we can also capture them in multiple and
the same probe can also
capture multiple parts of the chromosome
and that's where the novelty and
efficiency comes in
so to go through the workflow at a high
level
first we do the capture and sequencing
this
the circle shows the fragments and then
the below that is the
four probes that are um binding with the
those fragments and capturing them and
then we error correct the reeds
even though the pack biohi-fi reads are
very very accurate
we still find it's beneficial to go
through an error correction step
and then we go through a binning step
where we've been the reads
first we've been on and off here that's
the big circle on the right
but we also use the order of the probe
motifs to the extent we can we also bin
the reeds per
gene and then we assemble each of those
bins with canoe
from the assemblers point of view it's
just de novo sequencing it's just given
the sequences in the band and de novo
sequence them or
assemble them in a diploid way
although we use um canoe and it seems to
be working well for us
any assembler can be swapped in
at that point then comes the gene
annotation step and again here we used
to order the gene probes to
locate the location to precisely
annotate the location of the genes in
each haplotype
and then using other methods that i'll
explain later we also
annotate the location of exons within
the gene
within each gene and this slide shows
the res
the results of our assembly tests
compared to ground truth and
we put we use two populations for our
validation
one is a european population and one is
the african-american
population
and the column two shows the different
experiments
that varied by the number of probes that
we used first we used
the initial candidate set of 200 probes
on the european
um set i should say each population has
eight individuals
16 haplotypes so all total we had 32
haplotypes that we evaluated
in these two populations um so we
started out with 200 probes
and then we went to optimize that 15
probes for the europeans
and then we tried that 15 probes that
again for the african americans
and then we had a final optimized set of
18 probes on the african americans
and we availa evaluated these assemblies
with three three main metrics
one is lg 75 which is the number of
phase contains
it takes to uh correctly a phase in
assemble 75 percent of the haplotype
the other is um coverage fraction
and concordance and you can see with
these 18 probes we had a lg 70 it only
took us 1.8
can takes on average to fully assemble
75
of the haplotypes with a total coverage
average coverage of 97 percent
in a concordance with a reference of
99.97
the um the cartoon
depiction below it is um shows the
contigs for a typical assembly against
the reference
that's 147 000 base pairs long
the contig is colored by per base so
agcnt
and you can see that it provides almost
complete and overlapping coverage for
the
for the whole um for the whole haplotype
there's one exception though which is
this little gap in qr2d l2 l3
every haplotype has this gene
and there's a small gap in every one of
them
and this was introduced at the pcr
amplification
step it causes this
in a really poly a t
long poly a t repetitive region there's
a region of about a hundred base pairs
that isn't uh fully um amplified and
that causes a gap in the
assembly of eventually between
a few hundred and a few thousand base
pairs long
this this pcr problem isn't unique to
our workflow
the traditional long-range pcr
approaches that have traditionally
sequenced this allele
also has this problem in our we've also
evaluated our assembly on whole genome
pac bio hifi sequences
and this gap does not happen in those
in those sequencing libraries because
pcr wasn't performed on those so in
whole genome assembly with this
assembler you can get
uh that the better metric is lg 100 to
count how many uh
can takes it takes to fully sequence the
whole haplotype as opposed to
75 of it and the main reason the main
limitation is this
small gap in that one gene
the most um impressive our interest
complex part of
um the assembling these haplotypes is
the recombination in the hot spot
the particularly strong recombination
hotspot in the middle of the haplotype
it's about 10 000 base pairs long and
if we zoom in to that 10 000 base pairs
in the bottom
this depicts a an alignment speak of
that
region to itself and so the
xx it's cut off at the top because the
important thing is at the bottom the red
diagonal line from lower left to upper
right that's just an identity line that
shows that
it matches itself but the other lines to
the right side
show where the where the haplotype
sequence um
aligns to itself but in a different
locus in a different location
thousands thousands of base pairs away
and the blue indicates it matches itself
in the reverse
orientation and the red indicates that
it uh
it's in the same forward orientation
at the very bottom i've annotated the
transposable elements that are here
and i highlighted the the alu elements
in yellow each one of those alu elements
has
a long l1 uh line element on either side
and that combination of the aluminum
line is where the recombination
spot is so you can see that the reason
this recombination hot spot is
so particularly strong is that it has
this the
at least three and a row of these
recombination hot spots two in one
direction
and one in the other and um hopefully
you can
appreciate why um this was the most
difficult
traditionally anyway the most difficult
parts of these haplotypes
to assemble
going and going back to the dot plot of
the a haplotype with the b
hepatite it's probably hard to see but
each blue box in this picture
is that same um blue
that the blue and the recombination
alignment that we just saw and so
hopefully you can see that there's
little blue boxes
spread throughout the haplotypes and
that's why that's what causes the
all these variations in the structures
and why recombination can happen almost
anywhere
in these haplotypes this isn't a problem
just for assembly it's a problem for
alignment too
and now um we i'm switching gears to
another project where we created the
first multiple sequence alignment of all
cure haplotypes
it wasn't possible before because we had
we have a situation where we have
um almost 70 um cure references now
each between 70 and 270 000 base pairs
long
most aligners can't handle that size and
the ones that can get thrown off by hom
topology so we were we piggybacked on
our full haplotype assembly approach to
create
a full haplotype multiple sequence
alignment of all care haplotypes
and the way we started was going back to
the motifs of these
capture probes if you look at the yellow
arrows
this time i annotated each combination
of probes
with a letter so from four to three is c
from three to twelves i and so on and in
this way we can
summarize each haplotype as a order
direct
order of those probes and we can
summarize each haplotype instead of
hundreds of thousands of ac's g's and
t's
we can some right summarize each happen
type in about 100 characters
and with that 100 characters we can also
easily create a multiple sequence
alignment just
like you would for any other characters
and so that's what we did here
this represents a multiple sequence
alignment of the cure haplotypes
to a resolution of within 5 000 base
pairs
then we use that high level um
resolution habits
well first of all we translate it we
transpose that
alignment into a tree and on the right i
annotated the
names of the haplotypes with their human
annotation
and if i draw the cutoff line in the
tree
right where the red line red vertical
line is
then the branches that are annotated
at that level perfectly match the
previous human annotations of those
haplotypes
thereby demonstrating that these motifs
reconstruct the human annotation
of these haplotypes and so then using
that high level annotation we can micro
we can
might we can micro align the dna
at the single base pair and get a full
haplotype dna
alignment of um
of the haplotypes and that's what's
that's overview is depicted here where
the gray is
alignment and the white is um gaps
the inset is a uh as a cartoon i made an
excel spreadsheet
based on the human annotated uh
the human annotations of these
haplotypes
and you can see that the structures
match
exactly as part of that project we can
um
contributed new haplotypes to the human
um reference human genome reference
consortium
and this is a depiction of alternative
haplotypes from their website
um on the left it shows the the total
number of
patches and alternative reference per
chromosome
and in the right i filtered by keir
in the current um release of the
reference there are 50 alternative
references for cure in the human genome
references
and we added um 19 in our project
uh the project with the popul the
european and african-american
populations
so now in the next uh
release of the human genome reference
there will be 69
human cure happen types and almost half
of those will be from africans or
african americans
and you can see that if you look at the
left numbers again
the next the chromosome with the next
highest count is 28.
so which is for chromosome 3 which means
that
there are three times as many
alternative haplotypes for cure in the
human genome reference
is there as there is for any other uh
whole chromosome
so i think we're all of us who are
involved with that are proud of the fact
that um
uh cure is well represented uh
relatively speaking
at least in human genome reference
and finally i'll wrap up by giving a
pointer to the
bio archive preprints we have for these
papers
the first one is the paper that
publishes the multiple
sequence alignment and that was done in
combination with a center for
international blood and marrow
transplantation research
uh the university of washington and um
cisco genetics
and the that paper um
produces the multiple sequence alignment
that you can download and use
and it also um talks about the
annotation
and uh implications for to your
haplotype structures
the second paper is the haplotype
assembly method
for pac biohifi reads it assembles and
annotates
cure haplotypes including the first
annotation system for
cure haplotypes at least the first open
and free one
and then finally the last paper is a
genotyping
software system that will genotype
presence and absence care of any reads
that can capture
the cure region it can be short read
long read
it doesn't matter as long as it's dna
from the full cure region
and i'd like to thank my i especially
like to thank my advisor rayquan
and my other collaborators thank you